el presidente de Ucrania voló y
mercedesky está en Bruselas donde se
reúne con los socios europeos en busca
de aviones de combate y demás flujos de
ayuda en la guerra contra Rusia en su
segunda salida del país desde el inicio
de la guerra visitó primero Reino Unido
y luego se encontró en París con el
presidente de Manuel macron ahora cumple
agenda en la Cumbre extraordinaria de
líderes de Bruselas Por qué se movilizó
el mandatario y serada fructífera su
Campaña en términos de armamento nos
cuenta más Nuño Rodríguez él es experto
en comunicación política e inteligencia
Y analista de Quijote el portal de de
geopolítica y estrategia gracias a usted
por estar con nosotros
Hola buenas tardes Solamente una semana
después de que se realizará la Cumbre de
kiev en la que semeski recibió a los
diplomáticos europeos se está haciendo
campaña por más armas pero en Bruselas A
qué responde este desplazamiento para
hacer pedidos presenciales y agradecer
los envíos de ayuda
principalmente lo que tiene que haber es
una comunión entre las instituciones
tiene que haber un reforzamiento un
nuevo acuerdo del contrato porque
estamos hablando de que hasta el momento
se estaban haciendo unas donaciones de
material defensivo hacia Ucrania y Ahora
parece ser que ha comenzado La donación
de material ofensivo esto es
extremadamente complejo no estamos
hablando de material que es sencillo de
manejar con lo cual estamos estamos está
implicado que si se está haciendo una
donación de ese tipo de material
previamente ha habido unas cuantas
sesiones de instrucción irregular no
sabemos dentro de qué protocolo ni
dentro de qué de qué convenios de las
fuerzas armadas ucranianas para el
manejo de material complejo de la otan
Qué es lo que está haciendo zedesky pues
evidentemente está solicitando como
lleva haciendo Ya mucho mucho tiempo por
todos los escenarios parlamentarios
estás solicitando recursos está
solicitando dinero Está solicitando
armamento y está solicitando logística
está solicitando tener una soberanía que
parece ser que Ucrania carece de ella
hasta el momento pero lo importante ese
que está preparando el nuevo escenario
de operaciones dentro de dentro de
Europa el ministro de defensa inglés
estaba informando al parlamento de que
unos 11.000 miembros de las fuerzas
armadas de Estados Unidos habían llegado
al país y están ahora mismo en
Inglaterra dentro de unas ubicaciones
que no han sido no han sido clarificadas
no han sido publicadas Pero lo que sí
que sabemos es que los 11.000 miembros
del ejército estadounidense que hay
ahora mismo en
en Inglaterra están especializados en
labores de inteligencia en labores de
Comunicaciones y en labores de
de operaciones especiales con lo cual
cabe suponer que va a haber una
ampliación del teatro de operaciones por
aéreo por medios por medios terrestres
por medio de todos los tipos de dominio
de la guerra en el en el escenario
ucraniano y que parece ser que la
involucración de todos los países
europeos y de la otan subordinados a los
intereses de Estados Unidos pues van a
seguir el juego qué es lo que estaba
haciendo Es simplemente coordinar todo
este nuevo aparato de bélico que va a
pasar de ser en defensivo a ser ofensivo
pero que sin embargo Rusia ya tenía
también dentro de sus análisis de
inteligencia Y tenía también preparado
este este nuevo escenario cuánto tiempo
van a poder estar los países europeos
escondidos detrás de las cortinas
simulando que simplemente están haciendo
donaciones para defender la democracia
Pues la verdad que bastante bastante
poco las fuerzas armadas ucranianas cada
vez están más mermadas cada vez carecen
de más miembros ahora mismo el ejército
ucraniano está reclutando a personas que
habían sido declaradas inválidas están
ejecutando a personas mayores y están
reclutando a menores de edad el capital
humano del que dispone ahora mismo el
ejército ucraniano es escaso no sabemos
cuánto tiempo va a durar sabemos
perfectamente que están teniendo graves
problemas con naves llenas de de cuerpos
y que tienen la obligación dentro de lo
que viene siendo la estrategia de
comunicación de comunicación del
ejército de no anunciar de no comunicar
a los familiares más de X difuntos al
día en este escenario Cabe destacar que
antes o después los países occidentales
van a tener que estar en el escenario y
van a que esté van a tener que estar
frente pero entonces como siempre lo que
está pasando Es que lo importante sucede
en reuniones privadas y para el público
y para los medios pues ahí simplemente
un saludo a la bandera ahora no
solamente a pesar de estas operaciones
que usted nos menciona estarían
sucediendo ocurre desgaste en el terreno
también los aliados de Ucrania empiezan
a desgastarse y agotar sus recursos en
esta campaña pública contra Rusia Usted
cree que es factible en ese contexto que
pase con los aviones de combate que pide
ahora se le esquí lo que pasó finalmente
con los tanques Leppard
hay que tener en cuenta que siempre que
ha habido una nueva donación de material
de Última Generación Siempre han salido
Pues todos los los cabelleros todos los
preparandistas anunciando que iba a ser
un Game changer que iba a ser un cambio
radical en el escenario de guerra
ni los javalines cambiaron mucho el
escenario de guerra tampoco lo van a
hacer los leopar Y si quieren ahora
mismo darle a esos leo para esos a esos
tanques una cobertura aérea con los f-16
y los 35 con los los
veremos a ver qué es lo que sucede pero
de momento
Rusia ha sabido sortear bastante bien
todos los nuevos escenarios bélicos que
se le han planteado o sea en este
sentido Cabe destacar que si están dando
un paso hacia adelante los países
occidentales Este paso ya estaba medido
y el desgaste que está teniendo el
ejército ucraniano en pocas guerras
Hemos llegado a ver esto últimamente con
lo cual no vamos a tratar mucho tiempo
en ver graves cambios dentro de su
propio ejército hacia allá iba también
Es que este mes cumplimos desde que
inició la Guerra ahora qué es según este
análisis que usted hace lo que puede
cambiar el ritmo del conflicto
llegar a ver una escala de bélica pero
también por parte de Ucrania por parte
de Rusia Perdón se está barajando mucho
últimamente desde el principio se había
bajado el uso de armas nucleares
tácticas Cuanto más estresen la
situación en el conflicto ucraniano pues
más se puede llegar a estar acercando
esta esta situación apocalíptica